you don't want this i want you always
a lot of you probably know the twilight
movies by heart but
what if we told you there was footage
from the films you may have never
seen i can't understand you at all
that's right
there are tons of deleted and extended
scenes that would have made the movies
10 times better let's check them out
can't wait to see what you're gonna do
next
the twilight films of course weren't
lacking in the bedward department but in
comparison to the books their scenes
were definitely numbered in this deleted
scene we get to see edward and bella
share a cute moment at the beginning of
their relationship check it out
oh fragile little human according to
director catherine hardwick this is
actually kristen stewart's favorite
scene of the film
unfortunately the adorable moment was
cut because of time constraints
your number was up the first day i met
you there may be nothing more awkward in
this world than meeting your significant
other's parents for the first time
okay maybe one thing meeting your
vampire in-laws
in this extended scene we get to see
bella explore a little more of edward's
room compared to what we saw in the
final cut like his journals filled with
decades of memories
i wouldn't read that unless you have
trouble sleeping
what is it with vampires and journaling
not all the cullens were obsessed with
bella like edward was
and in this deleted scene we get a peek
at just how rebellious edward was with
his feelings for bella emmett reminds
edward
she's not one of us in the school
parking lot we even get a glimpse of
bella's frustrations with the cullens in
this moment
this scene definitely would have given
viewers a little more info on how
edward's family was dealing with the
whole situation
this specific scene isn't deleted but it
was cut short the first time bella
dreams about edward in twilight we
really just see her restless in bed
but katherine hardwick said they filmed
different versions of her actual dream
i had a few other kind of crazy cool
ideas right on the spot
like this one where her dream basically
predicts their first kiss in her bedroom
one thing is for sure we wouldn't have
complained of that scene made the final
cut
there are a lot of epic relationships
throughout the twilight series
bella and edward of course but we also
have hashtag goal couples in alice and
jasper
rosalie and emmett and the parents
themselves carlisle and esme but
unfortunately we don't get to see a lot
of the other romantic duos that's what
makes this deleted scene between esme
and carlyle
so special their love for one another is
definitely
underrated here i hope it's romantic
speaking of relationships we never get
to see they also exist within the
villains of twilight as well
james and victoria are meant to be this
epic love or at least
have a strong enough relationship that
victoria is willing to risk it all
in order to avenge james's death in this
deleted scene we get to see another side
of this
very steamy relationship have a look i
do love it when men chase
me before things take a major turn for
the worst in new moon the cullens throw
bella the pinterest perfect aesthetic
birthday party of our dreams she gets a
new stereo for her car
and plane tickets to see her mom but in
this extended scene we get a little more
background info on the decor
specifically the cake bella even throws
in a little humor
you guys don't even eat following
bella's horrific birthday bash and her
quick stitch up with dr carlisle
the viewers get a quick angsty scene
between bella and edward outside of her
house but kristen and rob
filmed the moment in between that never
made the final cut if you had a normal
party
it would come down to a band-aid bella
comforting a very conflicted edward
might have made his departure make a
little more sense but of course they had
to squeeze everything into two hours and
18 minutes
if i were a normal boyfriend i wouldn't
have to fight
the urge to kill you stop i don't want
normal
new moon is tough for bella even with
jacob as her distraction and if you read
the books
you'll see that she spends those months
without edward having intense nightmares
there's one deleted scene where we
actually get to see bella's nightmare
and her being comforted by charlie
getting to see bella bond with her dad
isn't something that's really focused on
in the movie so this is just
so heartwarming when your mother left
took you with her that was not a good
time for me
fleeing to italy at the last minute
would probably be a dream come true but
when it's for the reason of saving your
immortal boyfriend from turning himself
into the lethal vampire government it's
more of an
in real life nightmare that's why alice
second guesses bella's decision
in this extended scene maybe jacob's
right
well the voltori could see me as
edward's accomplice wait a second
did alice just agree with jacob for a
second that's a new one
despite literally planning to become
immortal after high school
bella still managed to graduate in good
standing the graduation scene is
admittedly pretty well
done and hits right in the nostalgia
feels but you know what would be even
better
a scene where charlie tells bella just
how proud he is of her
oh wait that scene does exist who
wouldn't want a touchy father-daughter
moment
it's customary i'm proud of you bills
the love triangle between bella edward
and jacob is very complicated and we see
a lot of overprotective edwards shining
through in eclipse
bella rightly so is a little annoyed
with his behavior to the point where he
even tells her
just keep the window closed if she
doesn't feel like seeing him at night in
this extended scene though we see that
no matter what bella doesn't want edward
to stay away
speaking of the angsty twilight love
triangle there's one point in eclipse
where
bella even claims she's switzerland also
known as neutral territory
smooth fella but what's missing in that
scene is that bella actually gets the
two of them to compromise with one
another for her sake
i know you guys don't like each other
but we've got bigger problems
this moment would have definitely added
an entire different layer to edward and
jacob's
very complicated relationship
thank the movie gods the eclipse
creators decided to keep in rosalie's
backstory because we all know
it's one of the more interesting ones
out of the cullen but there's an
extended version of the scene where
rosalie
mentions the one thing she wanted as a
human was a baby
aren't you just the best little boy ever
this might seem like a small bit of
information but it makes rosalie's
attachment over renesmee 100 more
understandable
if you hadn't read the books bella's
pregnancy reveal on her honeymoon came
out of
absolutely nowhere but if the creators
had kept in this deleted scene
viewers might have been able to pick up
the hints before
randomly increased appetite this island
must mess with my appetite or something
definitely a pregnancy clue in hollywood
not to mention this moment includes some
vital information about bella's feelings
if she hadn't gotten pregnant she was
willing to stay human a little longer
then you'd wait vampires and werewolves
just don't get along by nature
and that's the truth but rosalie and
jacob's relationship is extra strained
rosalie wants to protect bella's baby
and jacob just
wants the girl he's in love with to live
however despite the obvious tensions we
don't get much fighting between the two
except in this deleted scene enjoy
mongrel
rosalie literally feeds jacob with a dog
bowl we don't blame him for sending the
bull
straight at her face speaking of
relationships between vampires and
werewolves there's a deleted scene
between alice and jacob that may be the
cutest twilight moment we've seen yet
breaking dawn is a stressful two movies
for everyone and in this scene
alice and jacob finally get a chance to
breathe check it out
when i'm close to you it's like being
able to shut my eyes
how adorable would it have been to watch
these two warm up to one another in the
theater
well i'm glad i can help someone the
volturi is
obsessed with bella becoming a vampire
not only because
her being human and knowing about
vampires is a threat but also because
arrow believes she'll be gifted he was
right
either way to keep the red-eyed monsters
away the cullens makes sure to send
bella and edward's wedding invitation to
italy
except this wasn't seen in the final cut
it was released later on in a deleted
scene we still get the chills looking at
them
he's added a new member to his cover
having these scenes be incorporated into
the movie would have definitely brought
more clarity
and at times humor into the films but at
least we still got a peek at them we'll
take what we can get what was your
favorite deleted scene
do you think any of these moments should
have been included in the final cuts
we can't wait to read your thoughts in
the comments we'd love it if you hit
that subscribe button and give this
video a thumbs up
thanks for watching the things fans